اسبوعين انتظر هنا وزير داخليه طالبان
سراج الدين حقاني للقاء الزعيم الحركه هبه
الله اخون زاده دون ان يفلح انتظار يمشي
بشرخ في اوساط الحركه مصادر العربيه قالت
ان اخ زاده رفض لقاء حقاني بعدما وجه
الاخير انتقادات اللاذعه للزعيم الحركه
بسبب ما سماه احتكار السلطه وتشويه سمعه
النظام يجب ان يكون الشعب بكل اطيافه
شريكا في الحكومه مؤسس طالبان الملا عمر
لم يؤسس الحركه لينقذ القاده انفسهم بل
انشا الحركه من اجل انقاذ البلاد حقاني
الذي ينحدر من ولايه بكتيا شرق افغانستان
لم يترك فرصه للعوده الى انتقاد الزعيم
الطالبان سيما بعد تاسيس اخون زاده قوه
امنيه خاصه من المقربين منه وابناء قبيلته
المصادر ذكرت في وقت سابق ان حقان يسعى
الى تشكيل مجلس للحكم داخل الحركه ضمن
لتقييد السلطات الزعيم طالبان هبه الله
اخون زاده الوزير الذي سعى الى الانفتاح
على الغرب والحصول على دعم المجتمع الدولي
في انقلاب الناعم على قياده قندهار رفض
حصر التعيينات في الحكومه برجال الدين
تصاعد الانتقادات للزعيم الحركه ياتي عقب
اوامره بنقل اركان الحكومه من كابول الى
قندهار واحكام السيطرته عليها بعد ان نقل
مكتب المتحدث الرسمي باسم الحركه ذبيح
الله مجاهد ورئيس مركز المعلومات والاعلام
الوطني الى المدينه نفسها اضافه الى نقل
كتيبتين القوات الخاصه بدري 313 وفاتح من
كابول الى مسقط راسه ايضا
قندهار لم تعلق على انتقادات لحقان لكن
حاكم قندهار السابق سبق ورد على الوزير
بقوله ان الطاعه واجبه على الجميع وان
الزعيم ماض في قرارات ه حتى لو عارضها
العالم باجمعه
وتابعت
المزيد والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات